all right another day begins in Beijing
we talked with our um the person we're
renting our place from last night and he
said never the heck was that what's he
saying never eat the street food cuz uh
it can give you diarrhea because of the
ingredients they use so no he said
unknown the oil is unknown I'd like K
always corrects to while I'm making
these video updates he also said the air
pollution is really bad right now as I
showed yesterday in the videos and he
said we should get a mask so we're going
to go look for a mask and we're getting
hungry and there's no freaking place to
have breakfast here in China so we are
back to KFC it was sketchy we weren't
feeling it getting a bad Vibe so we're
going to cross the street and go to
McDonald's cuz there's nothing else to
eat here for breakfast Front no unless
you go to KFC or McDonald's it's crazy
so McDonald's for breakfast
hey
we found our masks we went to a pharmacy
and uh our guide said we needed to buy
one that said PM 2.5 what does that mean
I don't know which way does it go this
way on your year
[Music]
yeah wa that's scary it feels weird to
be walking around with a mask on but
it's normal here everybody does it so so
whatever we're going to be like Chinese
people for the day Nina and I just
stopped to take a
picture and uh we were well at least I
was trying to smile I was trying to SM
Nina was trying to smile too and then we
realized oh you can't see our
Smiles okay we're looking for the subway
off to the Great Wall here we go so we
just got to the uh train station to take
us to the great wall and we just missed
the train and the next one doesn't come
for 3 hours so we're going to do some
exploring and uh we took a picture of
the schedule we're going to come back
tomorrow so Nina got thirsty hungry
we're going to go to a 7-Eleven and then
head to the biggest flea market in China
so this should be fun we'll see what
happens so we're at the store here and
there's Guan statues everywhere I want
to take another one home but I already
have a huge one there but they're really
nice to
[Music]
okay it doesn't look like we're going to
buy anything here it's all uh jewelry
and some art and a whole bunch of of
junk too uh or at least we don't
understand what it is uh so not the
stuff we're necessarily looking for
we're going to do one last kind of look
around the outside and then head to a
new spot and see if we find something
interesting it's uh 3:00 oh ready yeah
we haven't eaten lunch we've only had
our our McDonald's breakfast and then
our snack our snack so getting a little
bit on the hangry side but I still love
you baby love you oh give me some
tongue
uh so we're going to go look for food
we're going to go to a shopping street
and hit up a market uh and sit down it'
be good to sit down for a little bit
discover something new walked around a
lot and got lost and then went to this
crazy mall that is hard to understand
and we finally found the place how you
feeling baby I'm
tired it's nice to sit down it is 3:42
and we're ready for our lunch
it's just honestly nice to to grab a
seat in a semi is a pretty clean place
so we're happy this is called slim taste
we're going to get some food and I'll
show you what we're going to
[Music]
eat so we left the uh restaurant to go
to the washroom and just outside we see
this huge brand new
opening unique CL three stories tall
huge line up outside so we're going to
go inside check it out nothing not
interesting at the UN clo same stuff so
we're going to hit up one last Market
before we go home and relax for a bit
cuz we're getting tired this one is a
sanley ton yashia clothing Market go in
have a quick look and uh continue
[Music]
on
so we started to uh crash inside the
market and decided just to catch your
cab and go home so so uh relax we'll see
if we want to go out again your eyes are
hurting eyes are burning the pollution
is crazy pollution is crazy let's see if
we can see can you see out here
it's it's just like you can't even see
all the way ahead cuz there s
pollution anyway we may go out tonight
or not we'll see tomorrow great wall and
then and then we go missing home missing
home want to go back to want home six
back to Toronto back to
[Music]
CH so that ride took us oh I forgot how
much time it was 18 minutes I think
whatever it was it cost us 26 Yuan which
is about just over
$4 not bad caps are pretty cheap okay
we're back to our main walking Street
this is the
Tesla promotion they're doing here and
our place is this way oh we stopped off
to get some some bubble tea
21 yeah yeah we went to the pharmacy and
I got some did you get I got some I like
being on camera instead of filming
everything this is
great I got some hold
on Grape layer
biscuits as a snack it was a hot deal on
sale so I thought okay I'm going to try
this I don't remember two bucks or
something and then and then I saw a
Dairy Queen and I thought o I need
something sweet but then we saw this
bubble tea play Like O that's even
better bubble tea and he look at the
menu what did you get and it's funny cuz
if you look here see they have these
little tapioca balls they the call them
pearls in China so the tapioca balls are
pearls so Pearl milky it's supposed to
be tapioca pearls see it says right
there in the menu Pearl milk tea okay
and but I like that they have a a a
cheese tea and a cheese milk tea it
sounds disgusting but it has a little
chef's hat so I guess that's a favorite
I ordered the uh the coconut coconut
flavored tea and what did you have mango
no I have the this the house special one
oh signs of milk tea Co
okay oh so they're making it now Nina
just hit some people as she was walking
back it was very close to H and uh we'll
see how it is oh that's fine and Frozen
is on
repeat
[Music]
cheers very
cool okay we just got home and it smells
clean already and we just turned on our
air cleaning machine oh it kind of looks
like a it's got two eyes and a mouth
kind of at least from here anyway good
to be home good to relax can take off my
mask my eyes are burning I guess you
can't really see anything can you see
anything eyes are burning nose is uh
super itchy so I got to blow that out
but we're going to wind down sit on the
couch chillax a
bit and maybe look for a salsa club oh I
don't know I still want to go shopping
oh Nina wants to go shopping okay well
plans tonight to be determined okay so
we
relaxed watch some of the profit had
some snacks I had a shower I had a shave
look at that mhm nice and
smooth Nina's laughing at me it's almost
9:00 and we're going to go out and get
some food I'm hungry Nina's Fine I'm
hungry and um we're going to maybe do a
little shopping for Nina I almost don't
want to go outside again and get all
polluted after I had my shower and put
the face mask on again but uh I don't
want to stay here just for the rest of
the night so we're going to go out see
what we find and I will update you with
the details okay so we came to this huge
mall close to where we're staying let me
and everything is is closed or um or
they have like two things on the menu no
God it's okay it's like not even 9:00
dude how does the restaurant close
before 9:00 anyway I don't get it but we
found one place
do and we're going to get
some pork rice yeah and
noodles so they gave us the stuff Nina's
carrying it we decided we're just going
to since them all closes soon we're
going to we're going to walk and shop
for Nina and then bring her home and eat
afterwards that is the plan okay we
didn't end up buying any clothes for nah
but nah found something else that she
really liked what did you get dried
plums and then this is the tea plums I
can put in the water drink get the tea
really yeah so you have Plum tea so
Nina's very excited about these
plums anyway we're going to we're going
to take our plums and our dinner home
relax and then wake up early tomorrow
and head to the Great Wall
finally hopefully fingers crossed
fingers
crossed okay we are set for our last
full day in
Beijing yay we're excited we're ready to
go home um we got a message from the guy
who uh got a message he post it on the
Chinese Chinese app so this is the air
quality measure where zero is safe and
zero is the green green and then the red
I don't know what the end of that red
line means maybe
death but we're pretty close to death
yesterday that was pretty bad and on the
message here says kids and elderly and
people who sick must stay
Ure this is what we're living with in
beijan anyway I'm glad I don't live here
permanently looking forward to going
back to Toronto and
City and uh we're going out today I
guess we're going to get our masks on
again yeah so we don't breathe in crap
okay off to the Great Wall finally woo
so we got to the uh the train station to
go to the Great Wall but the tickets are
already sold out like 2 hours ahead of
schedule it's already sold out and you
can't buy one for the next one uh for
another hour and then you have to wait 3
hours in line so it's it's kind of
ridiculous they don't have enough trains
going to the Great Wall we thought we
get here early it's our third day of
trying to get to the Great Wall and
having issues so we are here at uh
Starbucks n's in M we're going to uh
ease our concerns a little bit with some
coffee and then um head back and try to
catch a bus that will take us to the
great wall and if that doesn't work then
we'll probably just head back and relax
uh extra frustrating trying to get to
the Great Wall today but we'll see what
happens okay after a bunch of
chaos people telling us wrong
directions kind of you okay sorry I'm
not going to
I for 5
seconds people tell us on the wrong bus
better that better wrong bus okay wrong
bus uh just a zoo a crazy crazy Zoo to
get this bus um how are we feeling bab
I'm sweating it's supposed to be 21 it's
supposed to be cool but I'm sweating
Nina brought her uni jacket along just
in case cuz it just in case you get cold
but it's been very hot how how are we
feeling just to go Nina just
wants it's okay last Great Wall then
we're going home anyway we just got on
this bus we haven't eaten anything yet I
have no idea how long this bus ride is
there's no washrooms on here we're
crammed in like
sardines the look check out my leg
room SE the the the first seat we we sat
on I couldn't even put my legs down um
not not built for tall comedians I guess
anyway we're we're heading off we found
we found the right bus we're heading off
to the Great Wall we're going to have
amazing why
you and uh and then we're going to get
some food and hope we don't have to go
to the washing along the
way okay sending sending good Positive
Vibes out for great well happiness here
we
go
[Music]
already getting tired on these
stairs got to get back in
[Music]
shape
here we are at the Great Wall look at
that
[Music]
woo that was a huge rip off lunch we
ended up throwing away half of it time
we're going to explore
cuz it took us 3 days to get to the
Great Wall so we're going to have
[Music]
fun this is the Great Wall of
China
so somewhere along the the Great Wall of
China I I clicked the button on my
camera that uh muted everything so we
lost okay we lost all the audio from
every other footage from the rest of the
trip so what Nina and I are going to do
is go through our videos and record our
thoughts on what
happened and and you know add some
contact so it's not just boring
video yeah
okay so we continued along the Great
Wall we were having a hard time
breathing with our mask because it was a
a big uphill climb the stairs were huge
and and they was so polluted and you
have this huge mask on your face and so
we were having a hard time kind of
huffing and puffing climbing up those
stairs then we reached the end and
decided to turn around so on our way
down from the Great Wall we came up upon
this little village where where uh they
were selling a bunch of toury stuff you
could take a picture with a yak a camel
uh a horse or a bird I think it was a
peacock we didn't do any of that no no
we weren't interested in that and then
they had these Feed the Bears uh that we
skipped quickly on the way in because we
wanted to get to the Great Wall quickly
um but people were paying to defeat
these bears and that was it for the
Great Wall we got on the bus and went
back to Beijing we came back from the
Great Wall starving and the the food
there totally sucked and so we had to
find food as soon as we could and we
found this little shop that had bubble
tea and popcorn chicken Nina didn't like
the bubble tea but I did and we both
enjoyed the popcorn chicken and it was
great to finally get some food cuz we
were feeling a little uh woozy from not
having
enough then we decided to go shopping
again and once again we couldn't find
anything except Nina bought another
bra and then we got hungry and uh we had
planned to go to one of the top 10
restaurants in the
world uh called um ding Thao exactly
what Nina said uh they had some of the
best dumplings that we had to go and try
meat buns oh meat buns so we ordered
some beer started with some meat buns
that were yummy it it's basically when
you bite into the juice came out and
then the meat melt into your mouth it's
one of the most delicious things I've
ever had in in my life it was really
good it was melting your
mouth uh some veggies some fried rice
some vegetarian dumplings which were all
okay and then we ended with some almond
tofu dessert on shaved ice that was good
that was that was awesome and nah had a
little bit and then I had to fin I don't
think I even finished it it's really
sweet and humongous portion we shared
one yeah H I actually want some now the
total cost of everything to so so the
dine at a top 10 restaurant in the world
was 333 Yuan which is just over
$50 American uh and then we we left and
went on the street and we saw them
outside making it fresh and part of the
reason why it was so delicious was they
made it fresh in the store um as you got
to eat it so I want to go back just for
that oh we could go to first smup place
they have it there there's one here in
Canada which we might have to check out
we have to go check that out that was
delicious
so after dinner we went home and and we
ended up getting so excited because it
was our last night in Beijing and we
were tired of the pollution and and you
know we we didn't meet a lot of friendly
people especially in China and we were
homesick like it had been long enough we
like we we're so excited we're going to
go home we're happy and uh ready for one
last night before heading off the next
morning we woke up and we had scouted a
kanji Place nah was feeling Kani for
breakfast so we went over we found the
place that was just above the KFC that
we went to on the first day we had some
uh a beef pancake some kanji some egg
with mushrooms and they wouldn't give us
water they said they don't have water
like you can't get tap water just to
drink anyway it wasn't very good we
didn't leave very happy yeah but we were
excited to go home so to wash out the
taste of that nasty breakfast we went to
get a bubble tea and they gave it to me
it's a cold bubble tea they gave it to
me in a coffee cup
and I don't know I wasn't too happy
about that but it still tasted good it
was good to get the taste of that nasty
kanji place out of my mouth on the way
home uh we saw this little Amazon cart
and nah was freaking out like the Amazon
truck the Amazon truck was that freaking
know or you were freaking no I didn't
care I didn't even know what you're
talking about you were so
excited and then uh then we went back we
packed up and we were ready to
go we took a cap to the airport and were
uh in awe of how
huge the airport was and then I went for
our last lunch at Burger King and then
got our last Starbucks and we're ready
to board the
plane so when we got on the airplane we
had pre-booked the emergency seats so
that we had extra leg room and I was so
happy to be able to move my Fe you have
extra leg rooms I'm I'm short but you
still got extra leg room yeah
well I was really excited about the
extra leg room and uh I remember when I
booked those seats to get to Malaysia I
didn't understand how to get the TV out
there's this little TV screen that you
pop out and I thought oh no I don't have
a TV it's great to have the leg room
room but no TV I'm going to die how am I
going to handle the 14-hour flight to uh
Malaysia anyway and then somebody showed
me like 2 or 3 hours in that there's
this little thing you pull up and I was
so excited uh we had a bunch of airplane
food nothing uh too
exciting we got home we were excited
it's good to finally be home we opened
the door and um Hayden had left us a a
card that he made of a a wizard and my
parents sharpened our knives we had
dropped it off to them before we left
and then I was all excited at the end to
go weigh myself because I figured I was
going to gain at least you know 10 12
lbs or something cuz the last time I
went on vacation I gained a lot and you
guys saw how much food I ate on this
trip G 20b I gain 20 lbs oh my God I
gained a lot of pound anyway okay so I
was excited to get on the scale show how
much I had gained and then maybe even
make a a new video series about me
trying to lose weight uh and I got on
the scale it was only 197 I gained like
5bs or something I forget what the
original one was but only gained like 5
lbs and so I was happy that I didn't
gain much but then it was a little sad
because I couldn't make a video series
about me losing 5 lbs that wasn't that
wasn't a really exciting video it was
anyway it was so great to be home we
were really happy so thank you guys for
joining us on our trip I hope you had
fun watching it as much as we had fun
experiencing it and filming it and
filming it I think I I actually enjoy
watching back watching the videos and
and remembering what we have done it's
it's nice it is a good memory and and
and we love your comments coming in so
leave a comment leave a comment keep
watching thank you guys for joining us
on our trip and uh maybe we'll do it
again no we should we should yeah we
should okay yeah
[Laughter]
believe every week I share my best
information to help you fuel your
business forward in my newsletter Check
It Out
Below hi I'm Jason J rise fona of Rise
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period